[Aplausos]
miren
esto que ven en la pantalla de la
computadora es lo que está ocurriendo al
interior de mi cerebro en este momento
los lóbulos frontales que son los que
nos hacen seres humanos se iluminan hoy
en este preciso instante mientras yo
dirijo esta charla
y esto se logra gracias a este tipo de
dispositivos que pueden medir en el
electroencefalograma en tiempo real
yo soy un curioso de la tecnología y a
lo largo de los años he tenido la
oportunidad de ver este tipo de avances
especialmente para lograr que gente que
pueda tener algún tipo de discapacidad
pueda usar las ondas cerebrales para
controlar objetos como la mano que nos
mostraron en la mañana y estoy seguro
que eso va a llegar a ocurrir les voy a
contar ahora un poco del interés que hay
por las nuevas y esas voy a quitar un
segundito de esto para poder seguir
conversando con ustedes
las neurociencias no parten con nuevas
tecnologías en el siglo 21 este
dispositivo que ustedes acaban de venir
sobre mi cabeza permite una
retroalimentación en tiempo real de lo
que ocurre al interior de nuestros
cerebros cuando mucha gente hacía
meditación o yoga antes de ocurrir estas
tecnologías
creía que concentrándose en su
respiración lograba niveles de
meditación y calma apropiados pero en la
práctica no tenía idea si real entonces
estaba ocurriendo o no dentro de sus
cerebros hoy esto es posible y es
posible inclusive en casa con
dispositivos como éste
pero la razón por la cual hay un interés
enorme en el estudio del cerebro es
porque una de cada cuatro personas tiene
una enfermedad mental
y lamentablemente y de acuerdo a la
organización mundial de la salud
esta va a ser la segunda causa de muerte
en los próximos años después de los
infartos al corazón
y si la razón por la cual el mundo y los
seres humanos y la humanidad han
decidido hacer del estudio del cerebro
de las neurociencias una disciplina que
hoy hay que tener en cuenta y que los
invito a todos a interesarse a
estudiarla
hay dos proyectos uno en europa que se
llama el human brain project
ambos hay otro en estados unidos que es
el conector brain iniciative
el primero el brain project lo que
persigue es
un aspecto prácticamente teórico de
entender cómo modelar matemáticamente el
cerebro inclusive al nivel que permite
simular cómo operaría el cerebro
si uno le metiera una droga que
realmente no existe si no es virtual
para verificar como las neuronas se
comportan frente a esta droga y entender
las consecuencias que ésta puede tener
en un ser humano
el nivel de cómputo necesario para poder
hacer esta investigación es similar al
que estamos tratando de manejar en el
centro de aceleración de partículas en
genera donde coexisten estos dos
proyectos es decir la cantidad de
computación necesaria para poder modelar
un cerebro es equivalente a la que
estamos usando para entender el
principio del universo en el acelerador
de partículas en ginebra-
los americanos
aquí en una aproximación más parecida a
la que contaba gianfranco porque ellos
más prácticamente han empezado a
seccionar cerebros y luego a recomponer
los computacionalmente no han hecho un
modelo sino han simplemente ha replicado
lo que existe y están también teniendo
avances muy importantes en dónde y cómo
ocurren ciertas funciones en el cerebro
esto ha motivado en el hemisferio norte
un incremento enorme de gente que se
interesa por esta nueva disciplina con
la tecnología que hay hoy para hacerlo
como pueden ver en estas gráficas en las
maestrías y doctorados que están
aumentando en el perú lamentablemente
esta prioridad parecía que no es
realmente existente y yo me estoy
preocupando mucho de hacerle ver al
consiste por ejemplo la necesidad que
tenemos de hacer esto gracias a la
universidad cayetano heredia he podido
colaborar con ellos con tecnología para
hacer visible algunas cosas que ellos
venían estudiando especialmente en los
casos de esquizofrenia
en este mes con este tipo de tecnologías
ha ocurrido algo que en mi opinión no
solo es extraordinario sino a la vez
atemorizante hemos podido conectar a
tres personas
cerebralmente para poder comunicar ideas
entre sus cerebros sin necesidad de
hablar
este tipo de avance que ocurrió este mes
es uno de los pasos más interesantes en
la neurociencia moderna
y todo este interés que yo tengo por el
estudio del cerebro viene a partir de un
experimento que tuve la suerte de
participar en el ted en long beach en el
año 2013
ustedes ahí viendo cifras 271 mil 477
versus mil 182 mil 743
hay una diferencia de 48.5 por ciento
significa esto les voy a pasar el vídeo
de lo que ocurrió en ese experimento
conmigo y luego les explico
en ese estado
al ring
training piquer
episodio
con él
y ya
a la derecha
[Música]
el son
incluido
[Música]
ahora
sí
craig ha creado tengo
miren ese es un experimento que se
aplicó con un dispositivo que tiene más
sensores de la misma firma del que he
usado
y consiste en concentrarse en un solo
pensamiento hacer un ejercicio ahora por
favor y les pido que cierren sus ojos y
por un momento hasta que yo les avise
traten de pensar en una sola cosa y vean
si es posible que no pase algún otro
pensamiento mientras esto ocurre
es difícil y ahora los ojos por favor es
difícil concentrarse en un solo
pensamiento cada cerebro es como una
huella digital las circunvoluciones de
como el cerebro se acomoda dentro de
nuestro cráneo es particular de cada ser
humano para poder lograr un dispositivo
que permita leer un pensamiento concreto
y asociarlo a una instrucción de
computadora para hacer lo que vieron que
yo hacía que era pensando podía empujar
ese cubo en la pantalla y cuando dejaba
de pensar en ese pensamiento concreto el
cubo retrocedía esta tarea
qué es la tarea de que tiene que ser
entrenada además porque resulta que como
les digo cada cerebro es diferente
entonces el software que utiliza esta
tecnología lo que hace es aplanar todas
las circunvoluciones en un plano de dos
dimensiones y logra ver dónde ocurre el
área donde el cerebro se enciende de
manera más constante de forma común es
parecido a lo que ocurría al principio
de los 80 cuando la gente tenía que usar
sistemas que reconocían la voz humana
hoy todos en sus smartphones pueden
llamar a alguien diciendo llama fulano y
no es necesario entrenarlo y les digo
estamos avanzando porque esto ha sido en
el año 2013 a niveles que van a permitir
que este tipo de dispositivos puedan
leer el cerebro generalmente en todas
las personas el entrenamiento era vital
en esta situación
cuando yo no estaba enfocado el cubo
aparecía al frente de la pantalla cuando
yo estaba enfocado yo tenía que estar
pensando en una idea que puede hacer
cualquiera podía ser un color pudiera
ser la cara de una de mis hijas pudiera
ser un objeto cualquiera pero tenía que
mantener ese pensamiento sin divagar si
lo lograba el cubo podía ir hacia
adentro y esto mismo se puede utilizar
para poder mover cosas que son ajenas a
nuestro cuerpo como podría ser la mano
que mostraron en la mañana
lo interesante y también enigmático fue
resultado yo había estado experimentando
con esta tecnología antes de ir antes
acá en el perú con la universidad
cayetano heredia
y por eso me quedé en el puesto 21 de
1500 como el resultado que ustedes
vieron
lo curioso era quienes habían ganado no
ya vi flake es el número uno
con este resultado enorme 48.5 por
ciento más grande que el mío
esta otra señorita lince el loto wits no
logró leer el nombre del hito wikström y
sergey brin
con fundador de google
durante casa
cuatro años youtube realmente el enigma
de cómo esta gente lograba niveles de
atención y enfoque tan pero tan grandes
que superaban el esfuerzo que yo había
hecho para lograr lo mismo ese día
este es el ganador
en el verano del año 2017 un gran amigo
mío que se encuentra en esta sala me
llama y me cuenta de este libro
es el de robar el fuego still in fire
miren empecé a revisar la introducción
me compré el libro en audiobooks y esta
noche no dormía hasta terminar de
escucharlo en él estaba la respuesta a
este enigma del experimento de tête del
año 2013 en el silicon valley el estudio
de las neurociencias desde el cerebro es
algo intenso y realmente que preocupa a
la gente más rica que está avanzando con
lo último en la tecnología ellos han
desarrollado una serie de mecanismos que
hacen posible hacer que nuestro cerebro
funcione de manera excepcionales sin aún
realmente conocerlo en su totalidad
desde sonidos binaurales que estimulan
auditivamente las ondas cerebrales para
armonizarlas dentro de nuestro cerebro
hasta estimulación magnética
transcraneal que polariza nuestras
neuronas para lograr mejores efectos de
atención y también quitarnos depresión
aguda o estimulación eléctrica
transcraneal en particular he podido
hacer experiencias con ella y se los
digo uno logra niveles de enfoque en el
lóbulo frontal que son superiores a lo
normal y adicionalmente ese tipo de
enfoque no se disminuye cuando ustedes
pasan de usar esto anunciarlo sigue
aumentando es por eso que esta gente
está haciendo uso de unos espacios que
le llaman flow 2 en donde ellos entrenan
sus cerebros e inclusive con drogas eso
no lo ve obvio la verdad porque nadie
sabe el efecto colateral que eso puede
tener definitivamente este tema es algo
que tiene que ocurrir en el perú y que
yo invito y la idea es que ustedes hoy
vean en las neurociencias algo que
realmente es una prioridad y una
oportunidad para el perú muchas gracias
[Aplausos]